hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play a machine
for pigs okay we just got out of the
world ending out there and we're going
back into the machine which I hope means
that we're going back into the darkness
and I hope that means that the guy is
going to be trying to stop me at
whatever cost he can you know I haven't
seen another monster besides the pig
monster I'm hoping that he's got some
sort of devious creation that he's going
to onion some sort of creation that he's
going to unleash upon my hot piggy that
where I was supposed to go okay so like
with the lock before there seems to be a
big thing of compound to X little bit of
chemical X so if I aim this light at it
it should splode oh oh it's gonna blow
it's gonna blow
okay whatever you say men is that not
gonna splode doesn't seem like it's
gonna explode see this electrification
must be lethal to the touch now to
confound the machine and flood the
system this team this time not with
sewage but boiling sparking liquid death
okay so it's not gonna explode I thought
it was gonna explode like the lock but
apparently not all right so I need to
find my way down these corridors okay
that's not working all right there's got
to be a way there's got to be a way
through the dark involves into the heart
of the machine well I'm my destiny
okay cop-out ax no naked flames no
unshielded electronics if you say so
does this lantern count
all right is this is this compound X is
this what we're talking about here can I
send it careening into the machine I'm
guessing that's a yes goodbye
oh that did something this has writing
on it
Danger Danger Will Robinson how about
some more more no no more I guess I
don't need more I can go down now well
if you say so okay it's awfully dark
even my light doesn't produce much
hopefully we'll have a return to
subtlety here wait a minute can I
actually go down there doesn't seem like
a night I can actually go down but I
stopped the machinery nonetheless so
maybe that did something it's quieter
now which is better in my opinion come
on come on show me what you got yeah
seems to be compound X leaking
everywhere now which is my objective I'm
assuming so what does that mean
what does that mean
okay so somehow this light got turned
away wait a minute does that mean this
whole floor is like covered in stuff is
this working is this doing it what is
this doing no way hang on gotta get it
right on there okay so that's doing that
ah go got it
so hopefully that roasted up some
piggies other than that I don't know
what it was doing
aha that piggy is dead
Howie hey leo ha ha I thought I was
gonna die for sure there see Kurt chunk
hello thunk okay Pig line Pig line Pig
line is that like the line for feeding
in stuff the spark plug I mean it's my
machine I guess I would know how to how
to do it but this guy doesn't seem to
remember what he was doing his entire
life so all right then
breaking everything now barely see ya
whoa Nelly wait it out who do that who
did that machine I know what you fear oh
I will oh I can't touch it anymore to
your very soul I will destroy you
they're almost begun what does that mean
does that mean that I can stop it still
because it's barely started is that what
you're taught oh no I'm in water I just
realized I was in water that's probably
not good okay so this door is now open
so I can go to the Tri Paree or whatever
the hell that is
oh oh oh it's just rivers of blood oh
yeah
walking away from these temples those
temples the small pile of stones under
the rhododendrons the skulls of
innocence under the loose clawed
headless rib cages in the cool stone
behind the altars 3,000 miles apart I
traced back my life to this instance
rain channels eroded in ancient stones
the toxins are already in this damp
falling water i hack and retch and vomit
into the sink and grafts the bowl with
both hands and stare there in the
plughole is clear as day a toy spine
clockwork and intricate like a child's
spine but clockwork how could that be
how could a child spine be made like
clockwork I've washed it carefully and
placed it on the mantle beef by the egg
I laid myself what under the garden
where the children's skulls are buried
I call it my Mexico what oh hi piggy you
just playing there you'd be good little
piggies need a piggy go play they give
little piggy no no what
what okay why is there none who who's
calling what are you saying oh oh my I
am here again at the foot of those
stairs
what stairs towards the red light of the
nursery sunset in the window like a
bleeding sky the horizon a slit throat
the seeping dark to drain that youth
runneth I am the Jaguar faced man I am
the feathered serpent this priesthood is
mine
okay man just don't go to psycho bonkers
crazy
oh hello hi yes I know Oh
Oh Oh gross oh that's gross it seems
like something that's collapsed there
and it's just raining blood that is all
blood what the hell is going on in my
mind
yeah what the hell is with unfilled the
same thing I see something over there
she said it's just rivers of blood it's
just literally rivers of blood looks
pretty good graphically but uh and what
the hell is that I see something you
can't it's the little Kitty's again I
know it is I know it is yeah basically
what you gonna do Oh what are you gonna
do we're gonna do please no Oh again
with the heart ripping whoo yay
what the hell oh boy I'm in a river of
blood pipeline in stillness now blue
water runs in my veins now I'm here
oh yeah I carry the knife of this
Factory
the bowl of this mill I am coming to
collect you from your fields and your
furnaces I will gather you into the
white clouds I will gather you to me I
will take you say so man okay I think
this guy's completely lost it now
somehow the machines influence or
something like that I have no idea but
there's no way that this machine creates
this much blood and also with the
hallucinations in whatever what was what
is this it's a giant-ass room it's just
a big-ass room that I can barely see and
do I can't I know yeah if it's hard for
you guys to see it's hard for me to see
- I can't see anything oh look at the
dead bodies oh boy oh oh it's an
elevator it's rounded by Lake blood okay
okay okay alright then okay
but better it's much better it's much
better I like it the veil lifts the
bride is waiting
the man eats the pig and the pig is
eaten by the Machine and the man is
eaten by the Machine this is as it ever
will be
very great burning
okay are we just gonna ignore the fact
that everything was wrong are we just
gonna ignore that that everything was
blood I think we are I think we are
clearly ignoring that fact just carrying
on like nothing's wrong soon man this
will lose his memory once again then you
already know all I would tell you you
already know what you have done and what
you must do now walking away from those
temples that small pile of stones
beneath the rhododendrons the skulls of
innocent under the loose clawed headless
rib cages cruelly torn and exposed wait
didn't I read this already I trade I
read this and then that answers cradling
my children's head in my palms I knew
that I had to unbilled what I had myself
constructed though even then it was
little more than a sickening dream
this machine is ever mine and it falls
to me to redeem it in myself I've read
some of that oh it is quiet in here
oh it is here it is quiet in here I
walked these tunnels where no human has
trod before I am sure of that it is just
me and him now frost forms on my coat
sleeves the deathly still in the
freezing air tell me I am close close to
what vacuum eviscerate errs okay there
seem to be a lot of them are those what
caused the rivers of blood they extract
the vitae it's like a mass production of
what was going on in amnesia one oh my
it is quiet in here why did you take my
[Music]
Yeah right what is going on I hear
sounds small sounds great now this is
more like it
this is more like it okay is there
actually gonna be something down here or
what oh no you do not Oh what the hell
is that sound okay do I need to just
keep going forward I kind of don't want
to know okay are you just [ __ ] with
me is there actually something down
there or what what's going on what the
Frick of rag is going on here okay
is there actually something gonna pop
out of me of what that's what I need to
know and now
alright let's just know boss - [ __ ] that
bill what the hell's going on down there
what the hell oh don't start singing
this is what I wanted this is what I was
talking about in the last part this is
what this this is the good stuff this is
a good stuff right here
Oh No why are you being flickering
you've been training me the whole game -
whatever flickers
oh I think it was big I think was real
big ah thing was big
oh no it's kind of glowing blue - why
was it glowing blue it's gonna be a boss
battle oh I think we've big kind of
killed that thing all right here comes
Hogzilla okay where do I go oh this way
okay
or the vacuum
okay
okay okay all right
okay okay okay what is that
shut the F up you saw oh no oh no I know
it's gonna happen down that hallway I
know don't tell me I don't know a long
hallway and I saw a big thingy not gonna
give me that could give me not gonna get
me all right anyway I'm all out
shut up you kid shut up okay
so anyway I'm all out of time for this
part so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos it I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]